all right guys bang bang i've got keith
here with me how are you
pleasure to be with you i i feel like uh
there's the mayor of miami and then like
the king of miami and you may be trying
to uh take over that role
i'm very busy i don't need any new roles
trust me like i got plenty of funny
three two or three jobs to do already my
favorite job that i think you have is
barry's instructor which seems to be now
like a thing you're gonna keep doing
yeah once a month i try to teach a class
it's kind of a good challenge i get to
play dj uh go on stage turn my
introverted character into a moderate
extrovert
people love it so keep doing it um i
haven't seen you in class
no
dylan keeps trying to get me to go
delian is uh
uh at work hard trying to get video i
will go one time i promise okay good and
then you'll be converted it'll change
your life forever so don't worry that's
why i don't want to go is because i know
that that is the end state uh founder's
fund seems to be investing a ton
companies are all doing pretty well from
what we see in the press like what's an
update in terms of what you guys are
doing
it's been three years now since you went
to founders fun four years two and a
half two and a half okay like
good bad indifferent how do you kind of
feel about uh your last two and a half
years at founders fun it's well it's
been an interesting two and a half years
because obviously a giant founder's fund
before covid and then you know one and a
half years or two and a half years have
been post coveted it's a pretty
different experience than i would have
guessed um you know obviously we work
more remotely more distributed i've
obviously embraced miami in different
geos
none of this was you know sort of on the
radar when i joined nevertheless most of
the people in fact almost all the people
who work at founders fund i've known for
most of my adult life and you know so
everything about working with these
people is pretty much
as expected we've made a lot of you know
really good investments from the seed
stage to growth stage we now run you
know a venture fund of about 1.4 billion
dollars a growth fund of about 1.5
billion dollars so we invest what i like
to say 1 million to 200 million dollars
per round and you know do do them
equally as rapidly pretty much every
week um you know so anywhere in that
range uh so you know i've been very
happy to be an early stage investor in
several companies since i joined
founders fund we've now powered money
into the growth rounds in several of the
companies that i helped seed and you
know invest very early on a keynote deck
so getting to see the byproduct you know
two or three years later of the early
stage seed and series a stuff that i
like to specialize in how do you think
about investing with such a large funds
1.4 million in the traditional venture
fund
writing a million dollar check most
people would be like that's crazy how do
you make that work is it more so you're
buying access to the later deals is it
something where you're actually
underwriting it and if you don't win
future deals or get extra allocation
other than pro rata you're okay with the
ownership out of the gate like how do
you just think about kind of like
portfolio construction and initial
investment most of the time
i'm trying to invest enough money in
exchange for enough equity that if we
never let another round again i'd be
perfectly happy as an investor
that isn't always the case but 80 of the
time that's what i'm trying to
accomplish mostly because i'm
typically personally a pretty proactive
investor meaning i'm actively involved
with the founder sort of service pop
psychologist last consigliere to the
founder and so i want you know to have
the incentive alignment where if the
company does well and if we add value
that ultimately our lps make money uh so
that worked in door dash for example i
led the seed round in the very beginning
never let another round it's probably
returned one or two billion dollars to
coastal ventures
all right
how much have you returned to lps do you
think in your career you you your weight
is four or five billion okay um there's
a there's definitely a lot more in the
works um
but you know like how much more that
doesn't include well it doesn't include
stuff like that's clearly going to be
super liquid like stripe
there's things you know thought spot
there's clear public companies you know
that are going to be worth billions and
billions um but fundamentally and then
there's the new stuff at founders fund
but uh yeah it lags like the problem
with venture is obviously
all the stuff that's liquid is based on
decisions i made in 2013 and 14 like
literally uh so you don't know whether
still making you know really smart wise
decisions
even if you've had success historically
do you have a way to kind of gut check
your decision making along the way so a
decision you made in 2013 did you
revisit it in 2015 and you're like hey
that was a good decision bad decision or
how you kind of get it i usually know
emotionally within about a year
it's a little bit like a cake you want
to let it bake a bit you don't want to
over grate it early
you kind of want to sample it like a
chef does um but
the metric we used to use is subsequent
rounds of financing so you could tell
like by the valuation increases and the
velocity of increases how well the
company was probably doing at least you
know there's a rough correlation there
with the
market the way it is in the last let's
call it a year and a half i'm not sure i
would use valuation increases as a proxy
for success there's just too much money
it's just too easy to raise capital for
entrepreneurs so i think it's a it's an
unfortunately artificial metric right
now so we don't i don't have a empirical
based one that i would you know have
confidence in right now
but because i'm typically a board member
like usually i'm a proactive investor
join the board i have access to you know
all the metrics the kbis and so i'd more
look more look at the business examine
the businesses very specifically in a
detailed way and have my own conclusion
about whether the company's really going
to work how well what's the likelihood
and probability of success and
possibly the amplitude yeah do you
change the way that people fundraise now
given the environment change like should
and should founders lean into it and go
raise more money at higher valuations
and kind of capitalize on it should they
actually be more nervous and
be a little bit more disciplined like
how do you think about what a founder
can do
obviously being dependent on the
business but but just it does depend a
lot on the business so there's some
companies where they've clearly proven
enough that throwing more oxygen at the
problem will yield incremental success
and there's other companies where they
have not yet discovered the path to
success and throwing more money in the
problem may make things worse it may
confuse employees about whether they're
on the right path or not it may lead to
an artificially high burn rate which is
hard to change later may lead to bloated
hiring there's a lot of disadvantages of
too much capital but once you're on the
path to success often more oxygen is
good and the environment is definitely
entrepreneurially friendly right now the
cost of capital is very very low at the
margin to companies that appear to be
working
how has uh one of your core tenants just
the people you hire is the company you
build and just go get the best people
how has that changed now there's more
remote work and kind of this like maybe
not complete difference but there's some
companies for sure that are treating
employees differently they're able to
recruit different types of employees has
that helped or hurt these businesses
it's hard to tell i mean i
certainly still subscribe to the view
the team you build as the company build
more like sports
i think a lot of people get distracted
with technology but it's fundamentally
about the people and the right people
solve the problems and the wrong people
get in their way and the problems
are solutions so fundamentally
that's still what
i aspire to do with companies i'm
involved in whether directly or
indirectly
in a remote environment especially in a
very remote environment i think you have
to think about ratios of proven
experience and
up-and-coming talent a little bit
differently because it's difficult to
teach by osmosis so the way you would
typically build a company from scratch
and this is what peter kiel taught me in
november 2000 is you want to hire as
many inexperienced people as possible
that have high potential high upside and
that other larger companies don't know
how to evaluate correctly so basically
you want to lean into youth in an
experience
but
the best way for those people to learn
their craft is through osmosis in a
remote environment it's extremely
difficult if not impossible to teach
through osmosis so if i were building a
remote only company or remote first
company i might hire a different level
of experience than i would otherwise
prefer to do does it also change the way
that you onboard and train those
employees as well right so one you may
hire a little bit more experience but
you also can't kind of have what i would
consider more like of an apprenticeship
you have young people who are just
literally in the room every single day
uh do you have to be more thoughtful
about the systems that you put in place
or something to make sure that you're
actually offloading that knowledge to
you you can absolutely try that
what's unclear to me is how you teach
through an unstructured
uh curriculum in a remote way so
structured teaching environment
that that's very easy to replicate but i
think it's a lot of the best learnings
through osmosis in apprenticeship are
actually unstructured conversations and
i don't really know how to do that in a
remote world
uh you started open store
which is a great name given the past
success of the few of the last endeavor
uh what was the idea for this and kind
of how did you think through um you know
why you wanted to uh
to start it so jack abraham of atomic
came up with the idea for open store and
it really was predicated on the idea
that you know shopify has exploded the
the biggest surprise probably the last
10 years in technology has been the
success of shopify 180 billion
in a public market cap company really
displacing amazon actually is the future
of online consumption
and at the end of the day though
not all the businesses on shopify
there's 1.7 billion businesses currently
on shopify are going to be venture
backable
in fact most of them are not many of
them are not even debt financiable and
so this long tail of shopify merchants
let's say a million of the 1.7 million
really don't have um exits or access to
liquidity and so we felt that the best
thing we could do was provide liquidity
for these merchants and stitch together
these individual merchants into one
cohesive experience and so by providing
access to liquidity it encourages more
people to start shopify businesses
because instead of thinking you have to
run a business forever or you have to be
the one percent of the one percent that
venture capital makes sense for you now
have passed to life-changing wealth so
for example we can buy an open store a
business for one two three four five
million dollars which if you don't live
in california is actually a significant
amount of money that you get to you know
change your life
change your family's life and so we're
doing that all day long so it basically
was predicated on a notion that we had
at square
where before square if you were a long
tail business in america it was very
difficult to get access to visa
mastercard amex networks you had to
apply if you say we're selling less than
a hundred thousand dollars a year it was
virtually impossible and you'd have to
apply for what was known as a merchant
account it would take two to four weeks
you'd have to undergo a credit check
someone would physically come and
inspect your store and count your skus
and we made that instant overnight where
anybody could apply instantly be
approved actually we approved 93 of
everybody um and be underwritten to
process credit cards and grow their
business so it encouraged people to
start businesses encourage people and
enable people to grow their businesses
and that's what we're doing basically in
shopify we're encouraging people to
start new businesses and we're going to
give them access to liquidity so when
they no longer want to run the business
they have access to wealth why shopify
and not uh amazon uh shop well so
shopify stores um are actually basically
mostly run by the proprietor amazon has
optimized things to death they
suspicious with customer purchase
experience they optimize the delivery
experience they optimize the discovery
experience shopify merchants basically
acquire their own customers typically
through instagram or youtube or
something social media and then they
basically have to provide the
fulfillment and a lot of the logistical
support so there's a lot of room to
improve the businesses after we acquire
them whereas amazon stores are pretty
darwinistically evolved yeah when you
think about uh after the acquisition is
this something where you all want to run
them do you want to offload them and no
we will be running 100 of the businesses
we acquire okay that sounds very
daunting how do you do that in terms of
i'm assuming you're going to buy across
all verticals so how do you go from i
like your business you're running it i'm
going to give you money go away i just
changed your life but now my team's
going to take over it and do that we're
going to productize most of this so the
goal is to build a scalable technology
company that substitutes human labor
with technology and product so some
things can be templatized some things
can be automated there may be some
manual labor still involved but think of
customer support there's a lot of things
that customer support reps do that can
absolutely be automated or are a
function of product failures one of my
major hypotheses in life is that every
customer support inquiry is a function
of a product flaw someone doesn't know
how to do something that you want them
to be able to do so for example when you
use your microwave oven you never
contact customer support even when you
can't figure out what you know crazy
features advanced features and how to
activate them properly there's always a
default way to make the microwave oven
just work and every product whether it's
an app a website should have that
default experience and we're going to
build that default experience so
customer support i think most people can
kind of work their way through mentally
how you get there
so right now these long tail merchants
actually have to kind of basically take
someone literally to the fedex store or
whatever and drop off the package and
pay an inflated off-the-shelf rate at
scale we'll have volume discounts which
means we can charge customers less money
and they can probably get their packages
faster and so when you do that that
really allows you to buy a business
certain multiple it gives you better
unit economics and the whole model kind
of works because you're just driving
more and more revenue more profitability
it's a better experience for the user
you kind of have that alignment with
those end customers that's phase one and
phase two also we do intend to
take buyers that used to buy just from
keith's store and introduce them to the
pumps new store and so cross-pollinating
buyers based upon some data also will
help improve the value of what we're
creating how important is it to keep the
existing brand so if i buy keith's store
open store buys key store and you don't
buy mine
at some point do you come to me and say
hey you should join us and also we're
going to rename it keith's store as well
or it's unclear right now for the short
term we're definitely going to keep the
brands alive
i don't know it may be neither it may
not be binary over time there may be
some verticals where the brand is
critical and indispensable and to be a
fool it'd be a foolish thing to do is to
destroy that brand value and there may
be other cases where there's not as much
brand equity and it might make sense to
have a more unified brand i have a
friend who's looked at rolling up a
bunch of the amazon stores specifically
and one of the things that he told me
which was a little counterintuitive is
it's really hard to be
displaced once you've achieved some
level of search result kind of
superiority um and so it's almost like
digital real estate right hey if you're
the number one search result for
something you win
is there an equivalent in the shopify
ecosystem or is it just pure seo and
there's not most most of these merchants
are spending money on instagram ads it's
direct instagram to merchant acquisition
so obviously no one's monopolized
instagram
and then how do you think about this
rise of what i'll call like the creator
uh merchants so it's people who have the
big audience already that's great
because you don't have to spend much
money to acquire users but it almost
changes the economics of a business
because if they go away then you're
gonna have to spend the money because
you don't have access to their audience
anymore do you just disqualify those
types of businesses i don't think we're
generally buying like influencer-based
businesses we're really aiming for
long-tail businesses say let's say 10
sub 10 billion dollars in sales and most
of at least the most famous influencers
are probably exceeding 10 million in
sales yeah that makes sense uh miami is
obviously going very well yeah i'm here
you're here a lot of people we know are
here it seems like more people are
coming every day uh it was supposed to
be really hot
it's hot but it's not that hot no it's
much more pleasant here than let's say
new york
agreed uh and so it almost feels like
people were anticipating a slowdown and
maybe even a reversal of the trend
people were going to go back it does not
seem like that has occurred yet maybe it
does in the future how do you evaluate
success so far of like miami being set
up as a
technology hub and how important is it
to replicate silicon valley versus like
build something new
great set of questions so obviously
miami as a technology center is
uh
way ahead of schedule like when i first
moved here december 9th and announced i
was moving here last november i thought
this was going to be a 10-year you know
sort of crusade and which happens to be
nice as a venture capitalist we think in
10-year you know fun life cycle so that
was pretty normal but 10 years a long
time
we're now way ahead of the curve we
already have success the funding you
know just i saw a tweet yesterday that
just in the last five weeks over 452
million dollars have been invested in
just miami and that will continue to
accelerate because there's more and more
entrepreneurs here there's more and more
high growth opportunities ambitious
companies ambitious founders and the
ability to raise capital here is
actually easier as well we have several
founders that we've worked with that
actually either moved to miami
temporarily or permanently to raise
capital because they felt it was easier
and they've had a lot of success we have
one company that i don't think that dele
and i worked on together that i don't
think it's announced yet but had been
circumnavigating basically at the globe
trying to find um
access to capital had been rejected by
over 40 firms came to miami
met delhi and
dylan was instantly interested basically
proposed verbal offer you know the same
week and you know we've closed on and i
think that company's also going to move
to miami now so i think that happens
more and more when i first came here the
first sunday i had dinner with the mayor
and probably about 13 entrepreneurs that
had already relocated here and that was
about the entire set of people who've
already had it already had success and
technology that moved here
now it's probably more like a thousand
so you know orders of magnitude um you
know just in nine months and so i think
that's amazing this year
things are accelerating because
everybody for every one person who lives
here they have ten friends family
colleagues that also want to move here
so it just grows exponentially in a
classic sense
then secondarily last year because of
covid most of the magnets of getting
people to try miami were closed down
there wasn't art basel there wasn't
ultra all of these traditional
techniques of getting people to
experience miami and falling in love we
created a tech week from scratch there
was a hack week you know in august which
uh actually attracted 350 highly
qualified engineers so we we sort of
created our own momentum but this year
we'll be able to tap into the historical
miami momentum so i expect this year to
be like a 10x year in terms of
technology people one of the things
that's fascinating to me is people ask
me like why do you enjoy miami and the
answer i've just arrived at is like i'm
happier here yeah and i don't know how
much of it is like vitamin d from just
walking around outside versus it feels
like you can go to work and then when
you leave you can actually leave and go
do things you enjoy and go back to work
the next day is there like a one or two
sentence pitch as to like what you tell
people when they call you and they're
like hey is this real should i think so
what i tell people that actually are
intrigued by miami is please come visit
for at least a week or two and not a
weekend the reason why is you want to
experience miami as a real city if you
come for a weekend it's going to feel
like a vacation it's going to be great
there's a reason why people come myself
included used to come to miami for
vacations however if you
go through an entire normal week monday
through friday you'll see all the
benefits the biggest stark contrast that
people notice is absolutely the
happiness you can walk anywhere in miami
restaurant bar coffee shop office and
people are just happy and happiness is
contagious i think the sun vitamin d
absolutely has something to do with it
but the contagious nature of you know
any social network has been proven and
studied for you know decades actually
and then a third on top of that there
are just a lot of interesting things to
do in miami so you get the best of all
worlds you get excellent weather you get
happy people and you get an environment
where there's restaurants retail
athletic activities three of the i mean
actually in 2020 all four major sports
had the number one or number two team so
we're gonna regard art whatever your
interest is miami is the epicenter of
almost all of those interests one of the
pieces that immediately stands out to
most people is they come here and uh
it's debatable whether english is the
native language or spanish and it feels
very much like miami is the capital of
south and central america i always joke
uh but it seems like people really enjoy
that it doesn't feel like a san
francisco
where pretty much everyone looks like
talks the same you can't go anywhere and
get away from work or tech or whatever
is that something that you think is
important you know as people make the
decision or is it something that just
yeah there's some subset of people who
like that but that's not really one of
the main selling points uh it's
extremely refreshing to encounter a
diversity of thought experiences life
backgrounds in miami uh i think it does
yield better success as an entrepreneur
you have to think for yourself develop
first principles thinking be able to
articulate your views defend your views
which i think is
very in is quite indispensable to
success as an entrepreneur
second i think it the blending of
industries here is more natural and so
fusing entertainment or real estate or
financial services or in imported export
with technology is the future of
technology so the blending of culture
and technology is much better
done through miami than any other city
in the united states so i think you're
going to see different types of startups
emerge that would be more difficult uh
to succeed with outside miami
last question on miami is it seems like
there's a number of very influential or
leaders of investment firms that have
moved here we don't need to name them
all
how important is that to drawing those
founders like if it was somebody that
represented an organization but it
wasn't the founder or the decision maker
uh it feels like it wouldn't have as big
of an impact is that your read as well
yeah so you asked a question that i
actually didn't answer which is around
are we building a different version of
silicon valley or the same and i'm
trying to recreate
the parts of silicon valley that
propelled success and i think they're
different than
the let's say mainstream media likes to
cover so in my diagnosis of the history
of silicon valley which is based upon
lots of study and actually having access
to all almost all the people who built
the foundations of silicon valley um
i've actually interacted with personally
over over my life and my diagnosis is
different my diagnosis is that one of
the most important things was investors
so fundamentally sandhill road is the
most boring place on the planet the
office parks are drab dreary
cookie cutter
and the only reason sand hill road
became important in the history of the
world was there was a group of
people who had a slightly different risk
appetite than you could find in scale
anywhere else in the world and so people
from all around the globe would trek to
sandhill road
because they could find risk capital
that was different and differentiated so
my thesis was well i'm going to move to
miami and i'm going to bring the risk
capital that's different than you can
find anywhere else and i want to start
with angel investors because they're
actually the scarcest the people who
will give you money where nothing's
proven and they don't expect to get the
money back there's almost no places in
the world even today where there's a
scaled group of angel investors with
that risk reward appetite if you could
concentrate them then entrepreneurs will
gravitate towards them and then we can
bring the professional investors here
we're some of the most mobile people on
the planet so we can move to the places
that are most welcoming that the most
aspirational culture that have the best
weather that the best regulatory
environment the best family raising
safety profile
and then the entrepreneurs will want to
be here and that's basically what i
prioritized and that's exactly what's
happened so we get for example founders
fund is now investing more actively in
latin america than we ever have before
and i'm meeting latin american founders
who actually prefer to meet me here than
me go fly to them so it's become a
magnet for entrepreneurs some of them
will set up shop here some of them may
not but they want to meet me here
because there's a set of
vcs that they can meet all in one
efficient week than if we all
individually flew to columbia or to
mexico or brazil
when you think about meeting them that
early the angel investors obviously have
that risk appetite but how important is
that to almost uh top of funnel
recruiting also to get companies to move
here right if my investor is there if i
think i can hire engineers there i might
as well go build the company there and
then you almost are recreating a
flywheel that as that company succeeds
more people spin out they want to start
companies they go right back into the
same pool and is that kind of the idea
of how you do this yeah one of the
reasons why we started open store in
miami was i wanted to set an example
first of all for other founders if i
believe miami's the best place to start
a company i should start a company here
but secondly i suspect that lots of
people who work at open store have the
aspiration of starting their own company
one day this is exactly what happened at
square there's probably like five or six
very successful companies that you know
square colleagues of mine have now
founded
so i want them to start their companies
in miami the best way to do that is to
have them experience miami now and if
they're happy they're going to start
their company here there's no way
there's no way they're going to move
anywhere else so by having a magnet we
now have 29 employees at open store i'm
sure we'll wind up with 50 plus by the
end of the year probably a third of them
have some desire to start their own
company so they're going to create their
own companies here because they're going
to love miami do you interview all of
them
i try to i i'm probably running at 80
plus percent
and when you interview them are you
interviewing them for competency and
merit of like the job or the culture fit
or like how do you think about that
interview for some of that to be a
direct report it actually varies by role
um what i'm probably focused on
i'm probably interviewing for upside
potential is the most common and then
partially interviewing for
maybe organizational matchmaking which
is what what box what role should they
be in in the short term um some because
there's people who have a broad skill
set or and not as clearly defined skill
setting you're trying to match make
their talents against problems the
company and challenges the company has
so i'm probably usually doing one of
those two things how do you measure
upside potential or try to get at it
interview it et cetera i know you got
some good interviews well greg great
question
obviously that's the same thing to me
it's a species of the same problem of
how do you decide what founders to
invest in because you're not trying to
projec you're not trying to
assess where is this founder today
you're trying to plot out the future
trajectory three five seven ten years in
the future and so that's what i'm trying
to get um a feel for um i don't know
that there's a one if there's a magic
question to ask and a magic answer you
know grading
like a framework that you use so the
framework i use is what i'm really
looking for is a spike so let me talk
first from an investor standpoint it's a
slightly different perspective from an
employer standpoint as an investor what
i'm looking for is a spike and what i
mean by that is this person on some
dimension will be
in the top 10 basis points of somebody
i've ever met in that dimension so they
can be the smartest person i've ever met
they can be the most tenacious person
they've ever met the most creative
the most
reality distorting sales person the best
recruiter the best talent assessor but
on one dimension
they will just strike you as i've never
been anybody this good before in my
entire life and the reason for that is
truthfully if you're going to change the
world it's kind of a ridiculous somewhat
irrational goal the people who wake up
in the morning and say i'm going to
transform the entire planet or i'm going
to transform this entire industry you
kind of have to have an irrational um
disposition and the only people i've
ever seen succeed are so
talented
and so off the charts in at least one
dimension that you walk away from the
initial meeting and you say you know
what there's a non-zero chance that this
person could actually change the planet
and if you don't feel that in my view
the chance they actually change the
planet is basically rounds to zero so
i'll just pass as an investor so and now
in the employee context it's a little
bit different because you're not going
to build a company of just people who
are steph curry's like you can't
actually build a company of just steph
curry as investor you want to just
invest in steph curry's i was joking the
other day that with one of my colleagues
that i don't want to fund andre iguodala
he's a great compliment i'd love to hire
him but i actually don't want that's a
mistake when i fund him as opposed to
someone who has the potential to be
stuff
when you think about that one thing that
somebody is the world's best at does
that immediately have a trade-off of
like they're probably really really bad
at other things or usually for a
well-roundedness uh
i doubt there's anybody who's truly
well-rounded in that sense of like
they're in the top one percent of
everything um so there's usually areas
that they're either not interested in
and or not proficient at the
self-awareness is pretty important so
the the ones who are best have some
self-awareness this is what i'm awesome
at this is what i hate to do that's what
i'm about it and i'm going to go find
somebody who's complimentary to me so
that's the pairing is part of the art
that's actually one of the roles i've
sort of uh sort of have to assume as a
vc is helping source assess and recruit
the appropriate pair
you have a ton of ideas you've been very
successful building companies very
successful investing how do you decide
when you should
put together a team and almost like fund
it from the beginning and it's really an
idea that you're handing to a competent
team that you think can go do this
versus
you should start the business versus hey
this is somebody else who's bringing me
an idea and i should fund it like so 99
of the time
an entrepreneur is walking in with an
idea that he or she is incredibly
passionate about and possibly with a
team already you know an inco a team but
at least some team built around the idea
and that's what i do almost every day
it's very rare in contrast where i have
an idea or i'm willing to be the poor
person for an idea that say once every
four or five years kind of
you know sort of uh
decision for me so it's it's extremely
rare open store falls in that category
yeah so open store open door was my idea
and i recruited people to join my sort
of crusade finally after a decade of
trying
open store was not my ideas jack's idea
but it immediately sparked with me as a
a very good idea and right down the
middle of my specific unique skills that
was designed for me to do this it's
actually one of the reasons why i joined
square initially was i had actually been
planning to be a vc that summer
and
i got intercepted
and asked if i would meet with jack and
what ultimately persuaded me to take a
professional detour was the venn diagram
overlap of what jack and square needed
was right down the middle of my unique
skills which is some financial services
expertise and some ability to be
innovative and that at the time in 2010
was a very rare set of skills now it's
more common you could find a handful
easily of people that could do that
but open store because it uses under
we're trying to underwrite assets using
just data we're trying to acquire very
long tail businesses we're trying to use
a combination of math and data and and
people in a very elegant way is are all
unique skills that uh you know sort of
polished over 20 years it's like a keith
or boy playbook right there it is well
open source definitely right down the
middle like literally when jack pitched
me i think one minute into the pitch i
concluded this was a great and really
awesome and differentiated idea and
probably two minutes into it i was
pretty willing to commit to being ceo
was he gonna was he there to ask you to
be the ceo or was he pitching you for uh
an investor like how did that i don't
know what he said we had breakfast you
know like oh it was the day before
christmas in december last year and
i don't know what he you know i don't
know what he had in the back of his mind
but by the end of the by the end of two
minutes i was pretty convinced that i
was going to pioneer this one way or the
other we were going to will this into
existence and if it required me to be
ceo i'd be happy to do it
ramp is somewhat like square in terms of
financial services seems to be growing
incredibly incredibly quickly uh walk us
through like how you look at that
business and then why do you all
continue to double and triple down it
seems every time i talked to delhi and
or you ramp comes up at some point in
the conversation yeah ramp is an
interesting exception for me because i
almost never have a top-down hypothesis
as an investor typically an entrepreneur
walks into what used to be my office um
and says hey i've got the great the
greatest idea ever you know we're gonna
change the world blah blah blah you know
i just need some capital and some advice
and i'm like yeah that makes sense um in
the ramp case specifically i was
actually actively looking to fund
something a bunch of entrepreneurs that
wanted to tackle this specific problem i
thought there was a very big opportunity
there and that insofar as other people
were trying to tackle it they weren't
appropriate appropriately tackling and
addressing it so we were actively
looking at persuading people to tackle
this problem and that deland and i would
fund and then as we were doing that
delia intercepted uh
what was what became one of the founders
playing uh video games
and he said i think i found the people
and i said okay so i met with them and
actually
call it five minutes into the
conversation i looked at ellen
i was pretty impressed and i said you're
right you found the people to do you
told me we told him he was right yeah oh
yeah yeah definitely i was like we need
we definitely need to invest you just
found the people to do this let's we
don't we don't have to do this ourselves
and we don't have to recruit these other
crazy people to do this and
was it hard to convince them to do it or
were they they already they somewhat in
parallel had their own
goal of doing
something like ramp
and we happen to intercept them with we
want to fund someone who wants to do
something like ramp so it was a match
made sort of in heaven but he had
correctly found and accurately found the
people who could pull off the vision
that we had in the back of our brains
what makes it so special like i think
now it's a three four billion dollar
business it literally in a three-year
period or whatever has just come out of
nowhere why is it so successful well i
think there was a couple macro trends
that they were tapping into which is why
we were interested in finding founders
to tackle this problem which is at the
end of the day
almost every company is going to be
running on software modern software
and it started with small companies
running on modern software think sas you
know this product is service but the cfo
suite the financial services part of the
companies are running on legacy software
or using manual labor like if you look
at a public a company that goes public
these days the finance department is
typically a hundred people
and this is for a really a fairly small
publicly traded company and that makes
no sense whatsoever almost everything
done by finance can be done with
machines
and yet nobody had built that suite and
so we really wanted to find someone who
understood that vision that all
companies were going to run on software
and that someone could stitch the
software together to create value for
the cfo
we thought that there was very specific
apertures to go to market around access
to corporate cards for a variety of
reasons but that was always part of the
vision always like a step in the vision
i guess a phase in the vision not the
vision and then we thought that what we
needed was someone who could stitch
together the value proposition provided
by these cards into something that would
make sense to the decision makers within
the enterprise and eric and kareem had
the idea specifically around incentive
alignment which is we're going to help
you save money and here's how in a very
specific tactical way based upon
actually some of their experiences in
their prior startup so the combination
of the vision plus the practical
experiences of being able to connect the
dots was exactly what we wanted
i wanna switch gears talk about some
geopolitical stuff uh
china we can start there we can talk
about the book uh we can talk about
what's going on in china what was kind
of your uh assessment you you have not
been shy in the past about sharing kind
of your opinions so how do you look at
where we are right now
well we're clearly in a very
confrontational
uh state with china
and the only the only the biggest risk
is to be in denial about that and being
unwilling to admit that china has an
agenda that's very unfriendly to the
future of democracy
and china's been very strategic and wise
into their credit been very clever about
using technology specifically to achieve
their agenda and so my husband i wrote a
book um it's gonna be published by simon
schuster uh released on october 11th
called wires of war which details mostly
china's success
uh both using the front end of
technology
i think information content as well as
the back end the deep end the deep
technology
elements uh to manipulate democracies it
also talks a little bit about russia but
it's fundamentally a book about how
china's
been
manipulating uh democracy to the benefit
of authoritarianism and so we're gonna
we're gonna have to confront this one
way or the other uh we're gonna have to
compete in some dimensions we're gonna
have to invest in the military and other
dimensions this is gonna be a very
severe problem for the united states
over the last decade and the longer
we've neglected it the worse the problem
is there's an old concept in political
science that was borrowed from the
soviet union of what the russians used
to refer to as correlation of forces
which is basically you should always
compare your leverage as a military
force against the uh
alternative and the the ideal time to
attack is when the correlation of forces
is in your favor and as we've been in
neglect
benign or active neglect for the last 40
years basically china has been shifting
the correlation of forces to be closer
to in their favor
than ever before i want to kind of
bifurcate the conversation for a second
there is what i'll call more of like a
military aspect to this there's uh a
technology actually there may be a third
category which is like the capital
markets so let's start with capital
markets first of like these adrs and uh
vis um i was completely unaware of this
until recently started looking at it and
for those that don't know basically
chinese company creates a shell company
in the cayman islands they sell shares
in the cayman islands it's named
identically so the u.s investor unless
you're sophisticated you think you're
buying you know called 10 cent shares
but actually you're buying a shell
company that has some ip or whatever
address to it
is this something where the us is going
to say hey china you have to play by the
exact same rules as an american company
or is there going to be this game of
like national security and we're not
going to audit you and you can keep
doing this adr thing like how do you see
it playing out i think almost surely the
sec alone will crack down on this um i
think this some of the stuff was in the
works anyway and you know the
geopolitical reality will maybe
accelerate it uh
i think some of this was
um
there's a lot of people who've made a
lot of money in china many who have
served in republican and democratic
administrations that intentionally cast
a blind eye to this
but i think just given the macrodynamics
they're not
the politics are not going to allow this
to be swept under the rug anymore but
it's been abused you know for a decade
from a technology standpoint if you're
president of the united states like what
do you do
as a response to a lot of what they've
been doing
on that technology front
well i think unfortunately the united
states is going backward it's going
backwards from a government perspective
and advancing technology i think we have
to realize the future of the world is
predicated on technology and whichever
countries
produce the best technology are gonna
have the most power in the future and so
the best we can do is encourage
technologies and the best way to
encourage technology is to get the
government out of the way for the most
part there are some fields where that's
not true where there's an amazing
upfront initial investment that's
required for innovation but those are
the exception not the rule most
entrepreneurial pursuits can be created
with a very small amount of capital a
very reasonable time frame there are
some unique projects that require
massive investment that are like think
in the chips and semiconductor space
these days although the industries were
created with a fairly small amount of
money and actually did pretty well when
they had to be entrepreneurial but
fundamentally i think that's the
exception not the rule we also need to
truthfully appreciate entrepreneurial
pursuits meaning like one of the things
i like most about miami is this is
an aspirational culture where people
here are taught to emulate success not
penalize success and if we want more
entrepreneurial success we should be
emulating entrepreneurs not criticizing
them from a military standpoint i think
founder fund uh has funded anderl and
other kind of technology-led defense
approaches um is that our only response
is to basically uh meet improvement with
improvement or innovation with
innovation and continue to increase the
technical capabilities that we have from
a military standpoint well surely like
harnessing uh private enterprise
entrepreneurial talent like the
entrepreneurial talent on anderl would
be better or on par better than any
other company in the planet like they
recruit the best of the best and that's
certainly if we're in a competitive
dynamic we want to recruit the best of
the best that have you know our national
security interests at heart i think
having a vision that i'm an american
company i'm an american founder and i
want to help the united states of
america is a good thing and some of our
companies in silicon valley have got
away from that uh model mantra uh we at
founders fund love to back founders who
have that belief about the world that
being an american company is something
to be proud of and something they should
embrace and they should recruit on that
dimension and we're happy to provide the
capital if we're the only ones the only
vcs that want to provide the capital
even better
i i almost am laughing as i ask you this
are you investing in china all right no
yeah we have never invested in china nor
would we all right
do you want to elaborate as to why not
well i i think
you know
not certainly not just me but several of
my colleagues have had this view about
china at least since 2015 um where i
think some of this stuff was obvious if
you're looking i've actually had this
view on china
for 20 plus years that the the u.s
strategy of entanglement was actually
backfiring so basically if you look at
the history of china policy in the u.s
really we started embracing china in
1972 as a counterweight to the soviet
union which may have been actually a
pretty prudent strategy truthfully is
essentially somewhat clever um nixon
kissinger etc
but after the soviet union collapsed
1989 so pretty long time ago 30 years
no one really rethought what's our
strategy with china does it make sense
where there is no soviet union and we
never really reinvented ourselves and
rethought the policy from first
principles and then by certainly 1995
1996 1997 the intellectual bankruptcy of
our policy was very obvious so basically
it's lagged for 20 25 years and the
correlation of forces has worked it
started to work against us now because
of the neglect of the politicians and
the political class and the bribery the
actual motivation economic motivation of
people you know sort of
making money in china you're one of the
most voracious readers i know is there
one book that you would suggest people
go read that
other than maybe jacob's book
well i'll say to be fair jacob's
probably read 50 books on china so
you know he's definitely standing on the
shoulder or giants sort of thing um
there was a book i used to love it's a
little dated now when i was first really
studying china policy um written by
james mann i'm forgetting the title off
hand but i will tweet it
pretty sure that that was one of the
better introductory books um
i used to you know write speeches on
china policy back in the day and have to
study this stuff um and get quick up to
speed and i i felt like that was one of
the better ones um but um there's
there's now a quite serious library
sitting at our house of china books so
if you want the entire selection uh i
can walk you through the whole week
of our house
yeah uh all right uh afghanistan is
another place that actually now may have
some uh relationship to china russia i
mean it's all all kind of coming
together here but what's your view uh as
we sit here uh we're recording this the
u.s has decided to pull out the
pulling out of troops has been uh highly
controversial and uh i think at this
point pretty much widely accepted as not
done correctly or well um or maybe some
people still disagree with that uh and
now there seems to be violence at the
kabul airport and it's kind of getting
worse and worse so how do you just
evaluate i guess like one the efficacy
of what we've done so far and then how
do you look at what we're gonna do for
what we should do
i think it's certainly debatable about
what the right sort of exit strategy
from afghanistan is or should have been
i think many people with lots of
interesting perspectives have
disagreements on that
i think it's hard to debate the wisdom
and or the execution at the you know the
detail tactical level i think was insane
insane and extremely naive
and i think that's you know getting
worse and more clear every day
obviously i also feel that
many of the left-wing people in america
are extremely inconsistent with their
criticism of u.s policies
and their willingness to tolerate
significant abuses overseas so i made
these point years ago about saudi arabia
like i don't take money from saudi
arabia i think it's you know
they intentionally discriminate against
gays women jewish people etc and i think
that shouldn't be something anybody in
the entrepreneurial you know world wants
to
be involved in
the taliban is literally going around
executing gay people
god forbid if you're jewish you'll
probably get executed twice um you know
so like i just find it like
inconceivable that
the left tolerates um the idea of the
taliban running a country um where they
you know complain about the labeling of
bathrooms in north carolina um versus
stoning gays to death i think one is a
significantly greater problem and yet
they're totally you know completely
silent or they have the celebrities who
you know whine about this and that in
the united states which are pretty
tactical differences versus like
executing people
so one of the things that i've started
paying a lot more attention to is like
the memes of the internet really tend to
drive like what people feel the truth is
and it's almost uh not everyone can be a
comedian everyone knows comedians can
say whatever they want and mean it
barely well yeah but at least they get
away tim dillon has been a fantastic
follow for example on uh on twitter um
but the memes really are kind of that
replacement it's the way for a person to
say something and no one gets like super
super offended and so we saw things like
the taliban uh congratulations guys you
guys aren't wearing masks right you know
that type of stuff all the way down to
more of the more like serious uh things
that were going on and it just felt like
america woke up like almost overnight to
the fact that like we were negotiating
and you saw soldiers you saw uh special
forces folks combat veterans etc be like
wait a minute
we know that they're all in one building
and we're not just bombing the hell out
of it like it just felt like people were
waking up to what had probably been
going on behind the curtain for a long
time and
does that have like long-standing
implications of the way that people
trust you know one of the things i
always go to is like i do not think that
my generation of kind of let's call it
20 to 45 you're going to convince them
as the united states to go to war again
right it feels like that trust has been
almost broken and so you're going to
literally have to wait 20 years until
there's like a new generation of people
who you could convince unless some
catastrophic event happened yeah that's
kind of what happened post vietnam yeah
as someone was old enough to kind of i
didn't grow up until post vietnam
basically but there was a good decade
where it's basically impossible to
convince the united states to go to war
in any sense and that's why we wound up
with these proxy wars and like let's say
you know central america et cetera um
and it really wasn't until
yeah midway through reagan's re-election
um that that started changing in the
united states so there wouldn't be
time it wouldn't be surprising um
second though i do think that um people
are paying more attention to this and i
think that was basically where the bind
administration massively miscalculated
they thought this was going to be a
niche topic and a niche issue and kind
of be dusted on there kind of under the
radar and it's become top of mind it's
actually crowded out basically almost
everything else in the news and i think
the reason why is
things that were people were not paying
attention to
are so starkly and consistent with
american ideals in history that it's
actually causing people to wake up and
say what the hell are we what the hell
are we doing why are we doing this why
are we acting this way yeah um i have a
uh somebody that i know who uh we're
facebook friends and he's a former navy
seal and he posted recently a photo of
him looking at a watch submerged in
water and he said that at one point he
captured a taliban soldier and during
that uh encounter the taliban soldier
said to him you have a watch but we have
time and he remembers at the time
basically laughing at like you're an
idiot whatever and now he's basically
like he was right right and so i do
think that there is whether it's
afghanistan china whatever it just feels
like the american political kind of
system and the cyclical nature we're
just constantly worried about like
what's happening today what's happening
in six months
whereas some of these countries seem to
be you know maybe not 300 years but a
decade right it just seems like there's
a very different mentality for some of
the stuff than the american culture
allows yeah well there's a translation
to business and startups reid hoffman
taught me this is just one dimension in
any negotiation
is time and it's time your friend or foe
and understanding that allows you to
calibrate and manipulate other terms in
a negotiation and the same thing is true
in geopolitics explain more in business
so for example like let's say you're
losing money as a startup i'll give a
very simple example first but let's say
you're losing money as a startup
time is your foe right so every day a
deal doesn't happen that would be good
for you
it's actually
very painful whereas let's say you have
a market share and you're an incumbent
every day that preserves
your market share is actually good for
you so you want to go arguably want to
go slow so just understanding who who
time helps like what the defaults are in
a more conceptual way to think about it
and that's true in geopolitics people
with different time horizons might act
very differently yeah uh the media's
coverage of
the pandemic the afghanistan withdrawal
pretty much everything seems to uh be
received very differently and um
politics is probably the like
area where i think people can see it the
most clearly right now is uh this simple
example of like removed by didn't ask
president put trump if this was going on
it would be like a massacre right
in the media
how do you fix it like i think it's a
you know beating a dead horse that like
there's problems how do you actually fix
it or can you not fix it
it's a great question i i
i think some of the sort of
cats out of the bag in some sense which
is
gatekeepers have been removed and that's
what the media doesn't like in my view
going back to something naval wrote
maybe seven ten years ago
the reason why the media's hostile
technology is we've removed the
gatekeepers and their monopoly on
information power and control is
basically permanently destroyed and
people who are journalists don't like
that um so they hate the people who have
unlocked um you know democratization of
ideas and content
and they've been fighting back and you
know someone a losing battle but rear
guard action against technology and
empowering people
however
i think the model that does kind of work
is when i was living in the uk
you know there was basically
three
zones of daily publications there's the
conservative publications and there are
the liberal publications during the
intermediate ones and if you watch
people getting on uh you know sort of
the
subway system in the morning they would
typically buy two papers they'd buy
basically their favorite one which if
they're liberal they buy the one liberal
two choices if they're conservative
they'd buy one of the conservative ones
and they'd usually buy a middle one and
they were basically you know reading the
stuff they wanted to read with the angle
they wanted to read reinforcing their
own beliefs and then getting a little
bit of exposure you know to the middle
ground sort of thing and i think as long
as people know what the bias and
framework people are starting with is
actually can be very a very useful
exercise it's when the
media either masks their bias
professes there is no bias and then
therefore
surprises people and shocks people
that i think it's really unfair and
unscalable so i think we may see more of
an official sort of partisan partisan
nation participation i don't even know
what that word is um of the media and
that might actually be a fairly stable
solution
one of the things that this has kind of
shown itself is in the financial media
uh with the whole bitcoin crypto world
is uh most journalists will say hey i
can't hold a financial asset because i
want to be unbiased uh but if you're
writing about something that is
competitive to dollars right then you're
basically holding one side of the debate
and they don't disclose it there's bias
all stuff a second piece that recently
people have started to debate is if you
were a journalist you knew about bitcoin
in 2012 2013 but you weren't allowed to
buy it and now it is appreciated quite a
bit you actually may be negatively
biased towards it because i could have
bought it i didn't whatever
and so it almost feels like just we all
have to accept there's no such thing as
like not being biased and just everyone
put your bias out there and move on with
the world i think disclosing your bias
in perspective is probably the best
versus
trying to exterminate it
but not perfect i think there are better
and worse ways to reduce bias and i
think reducing bias can be helpful too
yeah last question or topic is uh
bitcoin where are you on it right now uh
so we've had founders fund been you know
long-term investors of bitcoin directly
over the last year we've started really
accelerated investing in
uh let's say crypto based companies
which is more new to us we were
historically occasional investors in
crypto oriented companies and very
bullish on bitcoin and we've now
invested in
five to ten crypto companies just in the
last quarter or two
so very active we just announced you
know a crypto based company uh this
morning um that's going to hopefully
reimagine the music industry uh but we
also funded several other that i believe
are announced crypto companies and a few
more in the works uh tell me kind of the
pitch around royal i know jd uh did open
door with you you've known justin for a
while what's kind of the
well the music industry is basically
broken because it's artifact of history
so traditionally music labels provided
multiple functions to artists they
provided a cache advance up front
and then they provide effectively
distribution so the cache advance up
front allowed an artist to live to
recruit collaborators you know think
vocalists or background musicians et
cetera et cetera and then traditionally
the label would get you know secure
procure placements on the radio to get
exposure for songs and actually ship
albums to retail and you know provide
all of the indispensable ingredients to
success for an artist and in exchange
the economics kind of works something
like 20 to the artist
and 80 to the music label
well nowadays distribution is not
the the industry the current labels
provide nothing in terms of distribution
we don't ship you know record we don't
ship records to record stores and also
cds even um secondly you know spotify's
algorithms or
tick tock or
the solar the artist's individual
following on social media whether
instagram or twitter drives adoption
and
nobody's really rethought the economics
do they make any sense when the label
isn't providing distribution it's just
providing a bit of cash up front that
bit of cash up front is basically
commodity
and so
one of the things royal will do is fix
that in the artist's favor the second
thing is obviously fans are you know
critical components of the trajectory of
both songs albums and artists and we
want fans to be able to participate in
the success and that's where we're going
to tap into the kind of movements you're
seeing in nfts where fans can be both an
economic and social collaborator with
the artist
last question a much more fun one uh i
was asking a couple of people what i
should ask you and this question came
out twice but i could tell you from who
uh there is a rumor that you have a fish
tank in your house that a scuba diver
needs to clean true or false i've read
that in real estate blogs
what a great answer all right where can
we send people to uh to find you on the
internet uh at rawboy r-a-b-o-i-s on
twitter or you can email me keith at
founder's fund if you have a really good
investment opportunity all right thank
you for doing this pleasure to be with
you
what's up guys bang bang a bunch of you
want to bring that trillionaire energy
every day and if you want to do it in
your financial life go use sofi sofa is
our exclusive sponsor because we think
they've got a great piece of software
that will help you accomplish your
financial dreams go to sofi.com today to
get started you can invest in everything
from etfs to individual stocks to
cryptocurrencies to ipos and they even
have an automated and best function head
on over to sofi.com
today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]
you